- Dans cette résidence privée
25 % des chambres sont
innocupé
STEVE VEILLETTE, propriétaire
résidence Domaine Saint-Désiré
10-11. C'est pas la place qui
- Alors que les urgences
débordent, le gouvernement
CHRISTIAN DUBÉ, ministre de la
Santé et des Services sociaux
- On n'a pas assez de lits qui
sont ouverts parce qu'on man
- Le ministre souhaite acheter
des places dans les RPA pour
y transférer les patients qui
n'ont plus besoin  hôpitaux.
- J'aimerais ça contribuer.
J'ai de la place. J'ai
le personnel pour. Je le fais
déjà arations de genoux,
de hanches.
- Je pense que ca serait adéquat
pour ces patients-là aussi.
- La proposition sueillie dans u
hospitalier.
Dr BERNARD SAMSON, urgentologue
Hôpital de Thetford Mines
- L'hopital c'est eux pas sortir
de ta chambre. Il y a toutesles,
fait que je pense que ces
patients-là seraient mieux
- Mais dans la grande région de
Québec, l'application pourrait
être ardue.
- Disons que je vais le croire,
- À Québec, 177 patients
lissent les critères
occupent des lits dans
les cinq principaux hôpitaux.
ils sont 83 répartis dans les
quatre h la région.
MARC FORTIN, PDG, Regroupement
québécois résidences pour aînés
Appalaches, ce qu'on a eu,
on a perdu beaucoup de RPA qui
ont fermé puis en plus, on a eu
moins de nouvelles ouvertures,
- Le détail de la mesure
n'a pas encore été
mais le Regroupement québécois
des résidences pour aînés
financier et du personnel.
- La main d'oeuvre, il y a
une pénurie, on n'est pas
capable d'augmenter les salaires
qui viennent avec. Deuxième
élément à ça c'est qu'il fa
que des employés des CLSC,
probablement, qui viennent aider
pour ces patients-là, à moinsqus
ses employés.
- Actuellement, au Québec,2000 t
occupés par des patients qui
ne nécessitent pas de soins
en centre hospitalier. Cela
représenc alors que les salles
d'attente des urgences sont
pleines à craquer.
Ici Magalie Masson,
Radio-Canada, Qué